open der folder on your desktop das
letzte mal dass sich ein horrorspiel auf
meinem kanal gespielt habe ist 70 jahre
her
und zur feier des tages habe ich mir
auch kein normales horrorspiel
rausgesucht sondern star survey falls
sie das spiel nicht kennen solltet
glückwünsche habt einiges richtig
gemacht in eurem leben des spiels tat
server unterscheidet sich
dementsprechend von anderen horror games
weil das spiel sich in euren computer
reinhängt mehr oder weniger also
erfindet während du das spiel offen hast
informationen über dich aufgrund deines
computers heraus ich habe allerdings
noch keine videos oder gameplays oder
irgendwas zu diesem spiel angeschaut
[Musik]
ok ich kann run zoomen wir werden das
ganz einfach mal selbst herausfinden
wir sind hier in einem kleinen zimmer
als sieht so ein bisschen aus ihnen
ziemlich beschissene hotelzimmer
bestehend aus einem schreibtisch ein
bett vorhaben allerdings können wir
hiermit nicht so wirklich interagieren
außer mit diesem screen hier server und
ich würde sagen ich dir einfach mal auf
jetzt nice day ab jetzt habe ich eine
wasser plan
ich kann die wasserflasche motto body
kann ich die wasserflasche auch
irgendwohin schmeißt oder irgendwie nie
hier kann ich ran zoomen space geht
nicht hier geht auch nichts ich kann
mich auch nicht bewegen oder so also ich
sitzt die ganze die auf meinem stuhl
haben jetzt nämlich keine wasserflaschen
rand kann ich sechs bisher noch nicht so
ganz
[Musik]
ich mach mal wieder zu
keine ahnung was ich mit dieser
wasserflasche hier jetzt tun soll ich
habe auch ehrlich gesagt die ganze zeit
ein bisschen angst vor dieser tür da
links aber gut wir kümmern uns mal
weiter um die fragen here you have a
nice day also bisher hab ich wirklich
einen ziemlich guten tag ich will have
many responsibilities also ich würde
sagen ja aber im vergleich zu anderen
leuten eher wenig also ich würde gerne
mittelding hier nehmen aber ich sage
einfach mal yes ich habe jeder sache
angst bei jeder frage michael braun for
women punkte zum joggen oder was
[Applaus]
es war der schatten vor der flasche you
will get your surrounding also fühlen
wir uns mehr oder weniger wohl kennen
wir uns dort aus keine ahnung was er
mich würde mal sagen jetzt okay okay
jetzt will er wissen wo wir uns gerade
befinden beziehungsweise ob wir wissen
wo wir uns gerade befinden
ich hab so ein bisschen angst nicht
umzudrehen weil vielleicht könnt ihr
euch noch aber eines länder videos
früher erinnern ich hoffe einfach nur
dass länder ging es darum dass wenn man
in diese richtung schaut das monster
also dass länder mit einem von hinten
immer näher kommt das heißt wenn ich
mich jetzt hier wieder umdrehen und
wieder dahin gucken wird jetzt wir haben
aber wenn er jetzt monster wäre okay so
hat man das auch nicht allerdings geht
es hier erst mal um die fragen also do
you know where you an ein weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
der wecker klingelt plötzlich und die
frage ist ob ich gegen eine panikattacke
hatte ja ich drehe mich jetzt auch
nochmal einmal hier im kreis rum im
zimmer ich habe hier gar nichts hier ist
immer noch nicht einmal das zimmer hier
also do you for your questions and
systems gehe eigentlich nicht gut weil
das ist ja wie sowieso ein spirituelles
interview ich glaube ehrlich gesagt ja
es gibt einen gott ich bin gläubig ich
bin katholisch aon string des crashs
oder freeware trink mich ja keiner dazu
dieses spiel hier zu spielen also
antworten wir auch hier wieder mit jesse
mich als immer noch nicht warum ich
diese komische wasserflasche in der hand
halten
ich hatte englischem aber ich weiß nicht
was fördern heißt bestimmt gewiss sicher
ich will auch einfach mal sagen ich hab
ja jeder frage angst und fiel kopfüber
in your room
jetzt hier gerade oder dann im spiel da
habe ich allerdings fragt du hier für
comstor uno mein gott das war ich mit
meinem halben schlaganfall hier auf dem
mausrad also in meinem zimmer fühle ich
mich gerade sehr wohl allerdings nicht
im spiel
ja also ich beantworte die fragen weiter
ich schaue mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
im zimmer um und sehe gar nichts have
you ever wondered manual sei jetzt klar
das licht ist wieder an leute
die tür
die sgs auf
muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
weiterspielen das spiel ich schaue mich
dennoch mal wisst ihr weiter um also die
tür ist auf entspannt hier ist niemand
ich schaue wieder auf meinem bildschirm
have you klingt auf ihr display die us
open egal war
ich hab den ordner aufgemacht ach so es
geht es geht hatte ich es geht um diesen
ordner hier von daher klicke ich einfach
mal auf open
da ist nichts drin du recognize the
contents of the fold bruder da steht
nichts do you have internet excel
ich habe mittlerweile ein bisschen angst
ja ich habe internet empfangen do you
have any ende ließ
ich würde einfach mal sagen ja weil
jeder mensch hat er irgendwie
irgendwelche leute die ihnen glaube ich
nicht für richtig mögen stan lee
westwood anybody kam looking for you are
safe also ich habe sehr sehr tolle
freunde auf die sehr stolz bin ich mache
das kirche im schädel solche raus
spielen also joel and yes
extreme die partie hier definitiv nein
dort brechen
licht ins spiel nicht im spiel nicht
drin ich nicht ob
[Musik]
a feeling we'll lodges programm live
maschinen meine gefühle sind real ich
habe gerade angst ist der meaning to
life jetzt der issing zu live mein
lieber herr gesangsverein meine fresse
do you know you get no
ich weiß noch nicht wer ich bin do you
know what is happening
ich weiß nicht wann ich mich dazu
entschlossen die scheiß spiel zu spielen
betonte truth about die existenz wurde
die neue den rock for better and yes ja
natürlich jeder mensch ich habe
nirgendwo meine damalige zeit warum
warum hast du meinen namen
ich klicke ich jetzt auf jetzt laufe ich
klicke auf jetzt
ja und er ist ja wirklich beantwortet
die fragen geprüft
natürlich klar jeder wäre wieder mehr
geschockt look out the window
ich schaue nicht nochmal aus diesem
dreck
around you ist ruhm bedeutet computer
der house.net
dawn of it is true that the world we
made you
[Musik]
ich bin schreibt sie vor ort ist erneut
feiner die dann sind hier überall sowie
narco zahlen erkennt finally got you
free ich nehme sie wirklich noch eine
wasserflasche hiermit das spiel hat sich
ja danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]